um you know and I I would argue that
it's a Eugenics movement what you see is
that the typical trans person is
actually an autistic girl think about
that guys they're sterilizing they're
essentially sterilizing autistic people
by giving them a sense of community and
family and making them think that the
solution to all of their problems is to
become a boy and then on top of that
they're allowing predatory men into our
locker rooms no I don't want to share a
locker room with a guy no I don't want
to compete with a guy no um I think I've
played volleyball for I don't know 16
years now I started playing when I was
10 I cannot compete with a man I am six
foot I am taller than most men yet a guy
shorter than me can lift more than me
and jump higher than me it doesn't
matter we're built different we're not
the same I